maybe intelligence and consciousness is
not something mysterious that can only
exist in meat blobs but actually maybe
it's all about information processing we
now know that you know it only takes two
gigabytes to store your entire DNA DNA
code like a typical movie download
there's not no big deal and it takes
about a hundred terabytes to store all
the information in your brain so if it's
really the information processing that's
that matters only well what why do we
need did it have it done and meat blobs
Ray Kurzweil for example would love to
upload himself into a robot before his
biological body gets too old so he can
keep living on is this science or
science fiction as a physicists I'm a
blob of quarks and electrons there's no
doubt about that and there's nothing
special about my quirks they're the same
kind of up course sound quirks that make
up at my the chair and everything else
in here so it's absolutely possible are
we gonna figure out how to do it in our
lifetime I think it's actually gonna be
much harder to figure out how our brain
does intelligence then it's gonna be to
build artificial intelligence and can do
all those same things just like it
turned out to be much harder to figure
out how to build a mechanical bird than
to build an airplane if you've seen the
TED talk of the mechanical bird and now
it's great but it took a hundred years
longer than that the Wright brothers and
if we succeed in building artificial
general intelligence even super
intelligence you know if that actually
happens in the 30 years you're still
young and healthy because you keep going
to the gym right then there's no
particular reason why one couldn't use
that technology to figure out how to do
uploading and all these other things
that that we want to do and just a
little word of warning you you define
consciousness there is self as a model
of self i I like more the definition of
consciousness that David Chalmers here
at NYU gives a simply subjective
experience you know I experience now
when I Drive no colors and sounds and so
on motions
of for self-driving car experience is
anything and before you upload yourself
or after you uploaded yourself into this
robot you know the Robo Christina that
looks like you and talks like you before
you switch on your off your biological
bot body I think you should make sure
that you understand whether it's
actually having a subjective experience
or it's just a mindless zombie talking
and acting like you because in the
latter case would be kind of a bummer if
you switch yourself off because the
that's it you know and and I think this
is a great challenge for scientists to
try to figure out the ultimately which
information processing feels conscious
[Music]